LaVon Kobayashi Billy plays for hatta
Berlin the 36 year old Georgian is
nothing if not versatile most recently
he's played in central defence
before hatta Kobayashi Billy played for
sheikha for six and a half years a
phenomenal 16-year career in the
Bundesliga has left him with a
reputation as a guy who keeps his cool
but he's also made negative headlines in
2012 he was given a record-breaking
seven and a half month ban for allegedly
pushing referee after a relegation match
between Berlin and dusted off but that's
not what he wants people to remember him
for that's what he grew his or her
that's why I accepted the ban I said
then I didn't want to end my career like
that I didn't deserve it I'll keep up
the struggle it doesn't fit I'm not that
way it can't be that one day I turned
into a bad guy I'm just the way I was
back then in 98 when I came to Germany
even when you came to five organ Germany
you were only 21 when you think back
what's the first thing that comes to
mind I've calmed you know it's asked us
anundson yeah as of a leak a doctor must
be honest back then I wasn't even
thinking of coming to the Bundesliga in
Germany at all get after 60 what I
thought about football and my career was
completely different guitar gear in
football Monaco I wanted to go to Spain
and play in the Spanish style I really
liked it even now but it turned out that
i went to fry borg and i'm still playing
in germany today back then it was
something really new something different
a new country a new language I couldn't
even speak German pas que cuenta con
deutsch program this Vienna that was in
1998 a very different time france had
just won the World Cup cuz I slow down
one the Bundesliga and Google had just
been invented when you think back on all
that what were the biggest most radical
changes you experienced in the home team
italia tongue it's kind of feel as it's
a the droopy oh there's plenty
there's a lot more pressure and demands
upon players and everything is much
faster if i compare how much players ran
back then in 90 minutes to what they do
now there's a huge difference the
conditions were all so different they
didn't have heated pictures for example
if there was snow on the ground we had
to play on out that's the way it was
it's not like that today hoy de sneaking
a sort yeah Annie you had 16 coaches but
you also played for one club for a long
time that's what they drive I wanted it
that way I could have changed clubs
after two years or so but I didn't want
to I want to identify with whatever club
I play for and do everything I can for
it that's why I've always committed
myself as such long periods I'll get you
mind if I hang people in Rio that's what
are the nicest memories you have
issuance the gup-c fuel is oh there's
plenty my first bundesliga match my
first bundesliga goal my first promotion
with fry Borg lots and then the recent
promotions in Berlin those were unique
even just the last matches at the
Olympic Stadium it was packed and when I
looked at faces in the crowd there was
joy and smiles it was really something
I'll never forget it I'm only going to
this video you forget in it that's mr.
than pursue what would have to happen
for you to play another season at hatta
oh they had the money you do I've got an
idea how to qualify for the Champions
League the 2015 final is in Berlin me
that's a real dream that's where that's
very very own it's wrong so you today Oh
outside immediately if that happened
everything has to be right there has to
be a reason for me to keep on playing
football